how severe are your symptoms if you eat  only a little outside of your all-meat  diet it's totally dependent on the food  if I had something containing gluten  very severe if I have something  containing soy like I was on tour with  Dad earlier this year and we went out  for lamb and they cooked the Lamb with  olive oil but the olive oil was like 70  soybean oil tons of restaurants Cheap  out and they cut their olive oil with 70  soybean oil anyway I had some the lamb  and I was like okay this tastes a little  weird because you can taste everything  if all you eat is meat for five years I  had a pretty bad reaction to just a  couple of Lollipop pieces of lamb that  had soybean oil on them but I'm almost  deathly allergic to Soy so that's not  that surprising I was sick for about a  week I cried the next day I felt  horrible I had this overwhelming sense  of Doom and it makes me weepy and my  joints hurt and my skin broke out and it  lasted for about a week